[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
SARAH HEWETT: All right.
I guess we can get started.
So today, we're going
to talk about what's
significant in
laboratory measurement
and how to take measurements in
the lab, how to do calculations
with the lab, and how to do
some of the data analysis
when you have a lot of
quantitative data, which you
will have in the lab coming up
when we do the Ellen Swallow
Richards or the
Charles River Lab.
One thing I wanted
to point out--
so there's hand-outs
in the back.
We're going to be going through
how to do the calculations
and how to do all
the statistics.
And there's an example
problem that we're
going to work through
as we go in the back.
So if you want to make
sure you have a copy
of that, that might be helpful.
And one of the things
that was pointed out
this week in the lab
is that in the lab,
there is a typo left
over from when we were
in the old labs in Building 4.
And so this Wednesday and
Thursday, the TA session
that it says, the
help session about how
to write the
ferrocene lab report
is going to be in the lab,
not in 4:00, 4:30 as it
says in the lab manual.
So just come to lab as normal.
The beginning of
the lab period will
be a quiz on the ferrocene
lab, so anything procedure
wise, calculations, reactions,
all that good stuff, things
that you should know, having
done the ferrocene lab
and hopefully having
started to write up
your report a little bit.
And then after the
first 20 minutes
or so, it's going
to be the quiz.
And then your TAs will give
a little bit of a lecture
about what they're looking
for in the ferrocene reports.
So that's a good time to
ask any questions about--
if you're unsure about where
to write anything, how to
write anything up
if you have anything
that you've already written
and you want them to look at.
They will be in the lab
to help you out with that.
And we have some more
office hours, too,
that got posted to Stellar.
And I will have a
slide about them
at the end of this lecture,
too, for more help.
But, yeah, day four of
ferrocene-- come take the quiz,
then get some help
on your reports.
It is in the lab.
You don't have to
go anywhere else.
Just come to lab as normal.
OK, so if we're going to be
talking about measurement
today, then we need to
talk about what things you
should be thinking
about if you're
going to measure something.
So if you're going to measure
the length of this piece
of wood with this
ruler, how long
would you be able to say
this piece of wood is?
AUDIENCE: There's no units.
SARAH HEWETT: There's no units.
Yeah, that's a problem.
What else is wrong?
AUDIENCE: It's not long enough.
SARAH HEWETT: It's
not long enough.
So what's the minimum we could
say about this piece of wood?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SARAH HEWETT: It's
longer than 1 something.
So this is not a
great measuring tool.
What about this?
Any better?
Slightly better.
So now, what could we
say about the length
of the piece of wood?
AUDIENCE: Between 1.
AUDIENCE: Between 1 and 2.
SARAH HEWETT: It's
between 1 and 2,
probably a little closer to 2.
But we can't really say too
much more about it than that.
And we still don't
have any units.
So this is just to
get you thinking
about what we need to be
considering when we are
choosing how we're going
to measure something
and when we were recording
measurements, what
information we can reasonably
get from the measuring tools
that we're using.
So to talk about measurements
a little bit more,
we're going to need to
talk about some terminology
and get this out of the
way, so that we're all
using the same language.
And you've probably
seen these terms
before in your other
science classes
in high school and middle
school, going way back.
But just as a quick refresher,
so we're all on the same page,
precision is how close
repeated measurements
are to one another.
So if you measure the same
thing a bunch of times,
you would like the
results to be the same.
And you've probably seen
these bulls-eye diagrams
where if the results are
all really close together,
that is very precise.
And you can measure that
with the standard deviation.
So the standard
deviation gives you
an idea of relatively how close
your points are to each other.
Accuracy is how
close a measurement
is to the true
value or the value
that you actually are
trying to measure.
So if you are
throwing darts and you
are trying to get the bulls-eye,
then if you have high accuracy,
then you have them
all in the bulls-eye.
If you have a high accuracy
and high precision,
then all of your darts
always go to the center.
You can have high accuracy
where you're always
around the target, but
your points are scattered.
And then you can have low
accuracy and low precision
where you're just
all over the place.
We measure accuracy
by the percent error.
So it's the error
relative to the result
that you're trying to get.
And the answers don't need
to be close to each other
to be accurate.
Like I said, they can
be spread out, but still
all close to the target value.
So these are some
terms that you probably
heard there a little
bit, used differently
in chemistry sometimes than
you may use them colloquially.
So we just want to go over that.
More terminology--
absolute error
is how far away a
measurement is from
the true or accepted value.
So if you are trying to measure,
let's see, with this here,
pipette, this
pipette is designed
to measure 10 milliliters.
And you can look at it.
And it has a tolerance
of 0.04 milliliters.
So that's an absolute error.
It is how far away
your measurement will
be from the true value if
you're trying to measure 10
and you measured 10.04.
Then your absolute error
is 0.04 milliliters.
So you just subtract
what you got
from what you intended to get.
The relative error is
how far a measurement
is from the true value, but
it's relative to the quantity
that you're trying to measure.
So if you've measured
0.04 or 10.04
and you intended to measure
10, then your absolute error
is the 0.04.
To get your relative error,
you'll make it a percent
and divide it by the 10 that
you intended to measure.
So now, you have a 0.4% error.
One way to think about this is
if you have an absolute error
of 1 milliliter when you're
measuring out 2.5 liters
of material, that's
pretty small.
But if you have an absolute
error of 1 milliliter when
you're measuring out 2.5
milliliters of material,
then that becomes a
much bigger problem.
So depending on the quantity
that you're measuring,
sometimes it's a little
bit more useful to report
the relative error
than the absolute error
and vice versa, depending
on the application.
If you say, yeah, it had
an error of 1 milliliter,
and your friends are all saying,
oh, you did such a great job,
and then you say,
I was only trying
to measure 2 milliliters,
then not so great.
Other types of error are random
error and systematic error.
So random error is things
that we can't really
control for or identify.
And it causes data to
fluctuate relatively uniformly
around a mean value.
And that's one of
the things that's
given on the uncertainty
in the measuring apparatus
that you're using.
So this pipette measures 10
milliliters, plus or minus
0.04 milliliters.
That is a random or
indeterminate error.
The data will fluctuate around
10 milliliters within 0.04.
You know that.
And you can control
for that using
statistical
analyses, which we'll
talk about in a little bit.
Systematic or
determined error is
error that has a known cause.
And that could be from faulty or
poorly calibrated instruments,
human error, or chemical
behavior inside reactions.
So if you intended to
get 5 grams of product
and you got less than
5 grams, then you
know that there is
some error associated
with your experiment.
And it could be because maybe
some of your iron oxidized.
Or maybe you spilled
some of your ferrocene.
Or maybe you were not tearing
the balance every time
you used it.
So that'll introduce error
into your measurement
if you were using the
equipment improperly.
Or if you're reading
from a burette
and you're always reading
in the wrong direction
or you didn't read to
enough significant figures,
that's systematic error.
And so that's not necessarily
from the glassware itself.
That's from how
you were using it.
And these are types
of error that you
can talk about in your
discussion section of your lab
report.
So you could talk about the
error that is associated with
the measurements that you can
control and that you cannot
control.
So the last term that we
need to talk about in terms
of when we're making
measurements or doing things
in the lab is, what does
it mean for something
to be significant?
So you may have heard of the
term "significant" figures
or this is a significant
result. What does it
mean for a number or
measurement to be significant?
And what makes a measurement
that we take significant
in the lab?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Ideally, significant
means all the numbers
that you're certain about plus
one estimate or one final.
SARAH HEWETT: Exactly.
Yeah.
So a number is significant.
And you report the
significant figures--
are in a measurement,
all of the numbers
that you're certain of, plus
the first uncertain digit.
So a lot of times, you'll
have some sort of--
you won't have
measurements every--
maybe tenth of a
milliliter or 1 milliliter,
depending on the size of the
glassware that you're using.
So you can be certain of
some of the measurements.
And then you're
uncertain of others.
So in our piece of
wood, we were certain
that it was bigger
than 1, but we were
uncertain of the next digit.
So we could estimate
that second digit.
And that counts as significant.
A quick review of significant
figures and how to use them.
All non-zero digits in a
number are significant.
Zeros in between non-zero
digits are also significant.
Zeros to the left of a non-zero
digit are not significant.
Zeros to the right are
only significant if there's
a decimal place.
And you can avoid ambiguity in
that with scientific notation.
So if we just go
through these really
quickly, how many significant
figures does this have?
Four.
AUDIENCE: Three
SARAH HEWETT: Three.
AUDIENCE: Six.
SARAH HEWETT: Six.
AUDIENCE: Two.
SARAH HEWETT: Two, maybe.
AUDIENCE: Maybe?
SARAH HEWETT: As
written, yeah, you
would probably call it
two, because the zero is
to the right.
But if you wanted the
zero to be significant,
then you could
write it like this.
And now, how many significant
figures do we have?
AUDIENCE: Three.
SARAH HEWETT: Three.
And if the zero is
not significant,
then to avoid people
being confused about it,
you could write it like this.
And we have two.
So that's one way you can
use scientific notation
to get around ambiguity.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
have a question.
So for 590, if someone put a
decimal point after the zero--
would it be three significant
figures, or would it be two?
SARAH HEWETT: So
that's a question
that I've always gotten.
I think, just
conventionally speaking,
if you wrote something
as like this, maybe.
More conventionally correct
would be to write it as 5.90
times 10 to the 2.
Because you don't
usually have a decimal
place if there's
nothing after it.
And then if you wrote
it like this, though,
then you have four
significant figures.
And that's more than you want.
So just go with the
scientific notation,
instead of having a
hanging decimal place.
Because that's not the
typical way to write numbers.
When you're doing math
with significant figures,
if you're adding
and subtracting,
then your final answer
should have the same number
of decimal places
as the number you
started with that
has the smallest
number of decimal places.
When you are multiplying
and dividing,
the answer should be
rounded to the same number
of significant
figures as the number
you started with
that has the least
number of significant figures.
So when you are
multiplying and dividing,
you want to count
up your sig figs.
And when you are
adding and subtracting,
then you pay attention
to your decimal places.
So if we go back to
our piece of wood,
then using that ruler that we
had earlier, we can estimate.
Maybe this is 1.8.
So we have gradations
every one unit.
We still don't have units.
Whatever this is.
And then you can estimate
this, one digit pass that.
And then our uncertainty is
our gradations divided by 2.
So we know that we are within
0.5 of the correct answer.
Because we can
estimate that it's
within this half
of our interval.
If we add more
gradations to our ruler--
so if we have markings
every 0.1, still no units,
then we can say with certainty
that our piece of wood
is 1.567 bigger than 1.7
and smaller than 1.8.
So it's 1.7 something.
You can estimate that
last decimal place.
And then your error gets
smaller to your uncertainty
in that measurement.
This is important in the lab.
Because you need to
make sure that you're
choosing the correct apparatus
for the amount of uncertainty
that you want in
your measurement.
So if you see something
in your lab manual
that says measure 1.2
grams, then this balance
is totally fine.
Because the balances-- if
you've never noticed at the top,
they have the uncertainty
written on there.
So the uncertainty is in
this last decimal place here.
So if you want 1.2 grams,
then you can't get 1.2.
And then your last digit
is the uncertain one.
Should always write down
all of the digits that
are on the balance screen.
But when you're going to
calculate uncertainty or do
an error propagation, then
you know that the last digit
is where your uncertainty is.
This is plus or
minus 0.01 grams.
So we have three different
types of balances in the lab.
So you want to make sure that
you're choosing the one that
has the correct number of
decimal places for the quantity
that you are trying to measure.
And the same thing
goes for glassware.
So the uncertainty
in the glassware
is frequently reported
on the glassware itself.
And there are standard
tolerances for various sizes
and grades of glassware.
So if you've ever seen
glassware that's volumetric,
it may say either
an A or a B on it.
So the A is the
highest standard.
And then B is a slightly
higher tolerance.
And there are standard things
of those that you can look up.
But it's usually written
on the glassware.
And so this is an example
of the 10-milliliter pipette
that I was showing you earlier.
So you can look at the pipette.
And then on the top part here,
it'll say 10 milliliters.
And this one says
plus or minus 0.04.
This pipette says
plus or minus 0.02.
So that one is calibrated a
little bit more precisely.
These are also
10-milliliter pipettes.
And you can look on
the top part here
to figure out what
their tolerances.
These are both 0.06.
And one of the other
things that you
need to make sure
when you are using
different types of
glassware is to figure out
where the markings end.
So these are both
10-milliliter pipettes.
And they are designed to
measure 10 milliliters
within 0.06 milliliters.
This one-- I don't know if
you can see it from here.
Probably not, but maybe
if I hold it up here.
The markings-- and
they go from 0 to 10.
And it ends here.
And there are no more
markings at the tip.
So that means the only time
you're measuring something
is when your liquid is within
where the markings are.
So if you're going to
measure 10 milliliters,
you need to start your
liquid here, end it at 10.
And don't go below that,
because that quantity is not
calibrated.
There are some pipettes
like this one that are also
designed to measure
10 milliliters,
but these have
gradations all the way
to the end of the pipette.
So to get 10 milliliters
out of this one,
you would fill it up to
here and then drain it
all the way out to the bottom.
So you want to make sure that
you check your glassware ahead
of time to figure
out how much of it
you can use to measure
liquids and what
you get if you empty
it all the way out,
versus measuring by difference.
If you look at your
graduated cylinders,
your graduated cylinders
are different sizes.
And the markings come in
different levels of precision.
So this has markings every
half of a milliliter.
And its tolerance is listed at
the top as plus or minus 0.3.
The 50-milliliter
graduated cylinder
has markings every 1 milliliter.
And at the top, it'll tell
you that its tolerance is
plus or minus 0.5 milliliter.
So again, that's the 1
milliliter divided by 2 rule.
So sometimes that holds.
And sometimes it's a
little bit different.
Volumetric glassware always
has a smaller tolerance,
so this is to 250-milliliter
volumetric flask.
And on here, it will tell
you that its tolerance
is plus or minus 0.12.
So you should always
look at these.
And when you are
making measurements
in the lab, when you're writing
things down in your lab manual,
you should always
write down what
the uncertainty in the
measurement that you're making
is.
So whether it's on one of
the balances or a volume,
always make sure
that you write down
what the uncertainty of the
glassware that you're using is.
If you look at
something like a beaker,
this also has a tolerance on it.
And it's plus or minus 5%.
So that's a lot
when you are looking
at a 300-milliliter beaker.
That's going to be
a lot more uncertain
than any of these other
measuring implements.
So it's good to know
before you choose,
what piece of
glassware you going
to use to measure something,
how precise you want your answer
to be, and how
much uncertainty is
acceptable in the measurement
that you are making.
With burettes-- so this is
a 50-milliliter burette.
And it doesn't have a
tolerance listed on it,
but it has markings every
tenth of a milliliter.
So what would be
uncertainty in the burette?
Point?
So if the markings are every--
a 50-milliliter burette.
The markings are
every 0.1 milliliters.
So the uncertainty is--
AUDIENCE: 0.05.
SARAH HEWETT: 0.05, so plus
or minus 0.05 milliliters.
In a 10-milliliter burette,
the markings are every--
let's see.
I think they're every 0.2.
No.
What are these?
0.05.
Yeah, these are every 0.01
in a 10-milliliter burette.
So what would the
uncertainty be here?
AUDIENCE: 0.005.
SARAH HEWETT: Yeah.
So make sure that
you are looking
at what glassware
you're using, and you
record the correct number
of significant figures.
Because it changes based
on the type of burette
and even within different types
of glassware where they are,
made different with
varying levels of quality.
So we can make one measurement.
And then we can figure
out what the uncertainty
is in that one measurement.
But what happens if we
take multiple measurements
and have to do math with them?
So if you look at
your worksheet here,
this is an example of something
that you might do in the lab
where you have done a
series of titrations
to calculate the concentration
of some sort of HCl solution.
So the first question is, what
is the uncertainty associated
with a 50-milliliter burette?
We already figured that out.
And then if we were going to
calculate the volume dispensed
in each titration trial
with the correct error,
how would we do that?
So one of the ways that you
could think about adding up
the error in these measurements
is just straight up,
adding the error.
So for this first example,
we have 12.52 milliliters.
This chalk is no good.
And then do volume
by difference.
We have 0.24 milliliters.
And each of these
has an uncertainty
of plus or minus
0.05 milliliters.
So if we added up the error
in these measurements,
then we would get
0.1 milliliters.
But it is probably
pretty unlikely
that both of these
measurements were off
by the full 0.05 milliliters.
So this would tend to
overestimate the amount
of error in your final answer.
So what we do is we
propagate the error.
And when you're adding
and subtracting,
you use the absolute errors.
Because you should
be adding quantities
that have the same units.
So units will be consistent
throughout your calculation.
And when you do this-- did
anybody subtract this out?
I don't know if anyone
has a calculator.
Got one?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
SARAH HEWETT: Great.
So if we subtract these
two numbers and we
get 12.2 milliliters.
And then how do we propagate
the error for this calculation?
So our error is going
to be the square root
of the squares of the errors
of each individual measurement.
So each one is--
so if anyone has done that--
or you do it in your head.
Why not?
The answer that you
get is 0.070710678.
So that's a lot of
extra decimal places.
And what we really care
about in uncertainty
is, where is the first decimal
point that is uncertain?
What is that first digit
that we don't know for sure?
And so we always
round an error to
the first significant figure.
So the error associated
with these measurements
is just 0.07 mL.
So to right this perfectly,
you would write it
as 12.28 minus 0.07 milliliters.
And you can
calculate the volumes
for each of those trials.
And then the error for all of
them is going to be the same.
Because the error for
each of your direct
measurements is
going to be 0.05.
So then we can talk
about what happens
to the error in a
calculation when
you are multiplying
or dividing something,
which is this next part.
So if you're going
to use this value
to calculate the
concentration of the HCl
in this fake
experiment, then you
will have to do some
multiplication and division.
And you'll be using
different quantities
that have different units.
So you can't just use
the absolute error,
because they have
different units.
So if you have your error
with your burette reading,
that'll be in milliliters.
If you have your error
with your concentration,
that's in molarity.
So we can't use
the absolute error.
So we'll have to use the
relative error, which,
if you remember, is the
absolute error divided
by the measurement
that you've made.
So you want to take
a second and do out
that calculation
for how to calculate
the concentration of the HCl.
Then we can do it all
together in a second.
And we'll just do it
for the first trial.
And then if you guys want
to have more practice,
you can do it for the
others afterwards.
So if we're going to
set up this calculation
for the concentration of the HCl
solution, where would we start?
It's the first
thing that we have
to do or to calculate in this.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Figure out how much
sodium hydroxide we have.
SARAH HEWETT: Yeah.
In what units?
AUDIENCE: Moles.
SARAH HEWETT: Moles.
So we can figure out
how many moles of sodium
hydroxide we have by
taking our volume.
And then we have our units,
our concentration return,
moles per liter.
So we need to turn
this into liters.
And then we can use our
molarity to get moles.
I guess we could do that as
moles of NaOH in 1 liter.
And then we can go from moles
of NaOH to moles of HCl.
What's our mole ratio?
AUDIENCE: One to one.
SARAH HEWETT: Too easy.
One to one.
Yeah.
1 mole.
And then we have moles of HCl.
And then the last step is to
divide by our volume of HCl.
Yes, which in this
case is 0.0100.
Yeah, liters.
And that should give you,
if anybody did it out,
0.60172 molar, hopefully.
So that's our concentration.
And now, we have to figure
out what the error associated
with that concentration is.
So we will look at
the error involved
in each of these terms.
So we have our error associated
with our burette measurement.
So our first one is going to
be the 0.07 over 12.28 squared
plus-- what's the next
error that we have?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SARAH HEWETT: Which one?
No, say it.
AUDIENCE: The last one.
SARAH HEWETT: Last one.
Yeah, we have error associated
with this measurement, right?
And the error associated with
that is 0.02 milliliters.
So you have 0.02 milliliters
over your 10 milliliters.
And then what's the
last error that we have?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Concentration of NaOH.
SARAH HEWETT: The
concentration of NaOH.
The 0.04.
So you have 0.04 over 0.49.
That's how you will
calculate your error
for the concentration
of the HCl.
And if you do this
out, you get 0.08.
So then, how would we
report these two together?
That's the thing from before.
So what is this?
What type of error is this?
Is it an absolute
or a relative error?
Relative.
So we calculated it from
all of the relative errors.
So this is a relative error.
And it's also-- you could
think of this as 8%.
So in order to get it
back into a standard error
that we can report
with our 6.60172,
then we have to multiply
these two together.
And if we go back to our
sig figs from before--
in this calculation, how
many significant figures
should our final
concentration answer have?
AUDIENCE: Two.
SARAH HEWETT: Two.
So this has two sig figs.
So we'll round this to 0.60.
Then you can multiply that
by your 0.08 relative error.
And your final answer should
look something like this,
way down here--
0.60 plus or minus 0.05 molar.
Any questions about
calculating errors
and doing error propagation?
So this is why it's
important to make sure
that you have the
correct tolerances
and the correct
errors associated
with all of your measurements.
Because when you go to do
all of your calculations
and write your lab
report up, it will
be very hard to figure out your
error if you are missing some.
OK.
So now that we know how to deal
with the various independent
measurements, what happens when
we make the same measurement
more than once?
And this goes back
way-- probably
to middle school when we talk
about the mean or the average
of a sample.
So in statistics land, they
call all of the possible values
that you could measure of
something the population.
And it's really hard to know
the true mean of the population,
unless you have access
to the entire population
and you've taken all
possible measurements,
which is pretty much impossible,
especially in the case
of 5.310.
We're not going to be making
all of the possible measurements
there are for each
quantity that we measure.
So in the lab, we
can take the mean
of a subset of the population.
We call that the sample and
then calculate our sample mean.
So population mean, if you ever
see in statistical literature,
is denoted as mu.
And then our sample
population is
denoted as the x bar,
where you just add up
all of your measurements, divide
by the number of measurements
you took.
And that's your mean.
So we calculate an average or
a mean for the HCl solution
on the back.
If you didn't do the
calculations from before,
the concentrations that you
should get are 0.60, 0.61,
0.61, and 0.64.
So if you add all those
up and divide by 5,
then your mean
concentration is 0.615
or rounded to the correct
number of significant figures--
0.62 molar.
The other thing that
you can calculate
is the standard deviation
of your measurements.
And so remember, that's
a measure of precision
or how close all of
your measurements
are to one another.
So small standard
deviation means
that all of your measurements
are very close together,
very precise.
And to calculate the
standard deviation,
again you could calculate
the standard deviation
of an entire population.
It's the sigma up there.
And then you need to know
your population mean.
But in the lab, we are
taking a smaller subset
of the population.
So we have to calculate a
sample standard deviation, which
is denoted as S. And the
major difference here
is that instead of
dividing by N, which
is the number of samples,
you divide by N minus 1,
so the number of measurements
you took, minus 1.
So to calculate a
standard deviation,
you calculate each
of your measurements,
subtract it from
the sample mean,
square it, add those all
up, divide by N minus 1,
and then take the square root.
And you can do this on
a scientific calculator,
a graphing calculator.
Excel does it for you,
any statistical program
that you want.
You don't have to calculate
this by hand in your lab manual
or in your lab report.
You could just show
the formula for it.
And then you can calculate
it using any sort
of statistical program.
So if we calculate
the standard deviation
for our concentration of the HCl
solution, then you should get--
not going to do this all out
by hand right now, because we
don't have a lot of time.
But if you wanted to try
it out later or check
your answer for somewhere
else, it should be 0.1732.
It keeps going.
So the standard
deviation is typically
rounded to the same number
of significant figures
as the measurements
that you are using
to get the standard deviation.
You'll see it reported
pretty frequently like that.
So we can report our
standard deviation as 0.017.
Since we are taking a mean that
is not the population mean,
we know that we may
not have exactly--
the mean of your sample
will probably not
be exactly the same as
the population mean.
But you can figure out
how good of an estimate
your mean is, of the
overall population mean,
by calculating the
standard error of the mean.
And that is done by taking
the standard deviation
of your sample and dividing by
the square root of the number
of data points that you have.
So if you want to get a
better and better estimate
of the true mean
of your population,
then you can keep
increasing the N value.
And eventually, it'll
make your standard error
smaller to a point, since
it's the square root.
Once you get a big enough
number of N, then incrementally,
you get less and less benefit
from adding more and more data
points.
But you can also make
your standard error
smaller by decreasing
your standard deviation.
And so if you can make
more precise measurements,
then that will also help
improve the quality of your mean
and how accurate it is toward
the actual population mean.
All of this is leading
up to doing statistics.
And all of statistics
is essentially
based on the
Gaussian distribution
or the normal distribution.
And you've probably
seen this before.
And this graph is
an axis of where
the x-axis is the number
of standard deviations away
from the mean.
And then the y is
the probability
of finding a measurement
in that space.
So you can see that
the highest probability
of all of your
measurements is going
to be very close to the mean.
So if you're taking
measurements accurately,
they should be very
close to the mean.
And then as you get
further and further away,
there is less probability
that some measurement you take
will be three standard
deviations away from the mean
and so on.
So this number Z is calculated
by subtracting your number
from the mean and
dividing by the number
of standard deviations.
So it's just essentially the
number of standard deviations
away from the mean--
your measurement is.
Oh, back up.
We cannot go back.
There we go.
One way that we can use
this is to figure out
confidence levels of the
measurements that we take
or the means that we calculate.
And so you can come to an error
under the curve analysis here--
or an area under
the curve analysis.
And so for all
measurements that are
within one standard deviation,
plus or minus from the mean,
that accounts for 68%
of the area there.
If you go within two
standard deviations,
you can stay within
95% confidence
that your mean is
within that area.
And then within three standard
deviations, plus or minus,
so 99% chance that your
mean is within that area.
So we can use this when we
are calculating the accuracy
or how confident we
are that have measured
the population mean
with the samples
that we have taken in the lab.
We can do this because of the
central limit theorem, which
states that the distribution
of sample means in a population
will constitute a
normal distribution,
even if the population itself
is not normally distributed.
So if you take a
bunch of samples
or take a bunch of
measurements in the lab,
then you can use the
normal distribution
to statistically
analyze them, even
if you don't know the
distribution of the population
itself.
So we can use that information
to calculate confidence levels
of a mean that we calculate.
So what that means is we can
calculate how confident we
are that our mean falls
within a certain range
of the actual population mean.
And you can say it with
different levels of confidence.
You could say I'm 99% confident.
And you'll get a wider
range or 95% confident.
And you'll get a little
bit of a smaller range.
And the range of the values
is what we call the confidence
interval.
And you can calculate
a confidence interval
for the actual population mean.
And that is your standard
mean, that Z square root
we were talking about,
times the standard deviation
of the population, divided
by the square root of N.
To use Z as in the
previous slide,
you need to have a
big enough sample
size that your estimates of the
mean and the standard deviation
are a good enough substitute
for the actual sigma,
the population
standard deviation.
That's really challenging
in lab situations.
And in 5 through
10, we will not ever
have a big enough sample
size for that to be the case.
So as an alternative, we
can use the t statistic.
So to calculate a confidence
interval for a mean
that you calculate
in lab, you can
take your mean, plus or
minus the t statistic,
times your sample
standard deviation,
over the square
root of N. And you
can calculate t statistics
using this formula if you
have all of this information.
Or you can get a
table of t values
for varying confidence levels
and varying degrees of freedom,
which is N minus 1, which is
the number of measurements
that you took, minus 1.
So if we're going to calculate
a confidence interval
for the mean of our
HCl concentration,
then we will have
something like--
we need our average, plus or
minus ts, square root of N.
And you'll notice that
this standard deviation
over the square root of N is
the standard error of the mean.
So if you calculate
that, then it'll
make it slightly easier to
calculate your confidence
interval.
Yeah.
And so to do that, we're going
to need some t table, which
gives you the t statistics.
Our average of the mean
was 0.62, plus or minus.
So the t value-- if we
have four measurements,
then our degrees of freedom is
going to be 3, so N minus 1.
And then we want to use
a two-tailed t-test.
Because we don't know
which way our measurement
is going to vary.
So the two-tail means that
it could be higher or lower
than the actual mean.
So you want to calculate one
that has a value of 0.05.
So that corresponds to the
95% confidence interval.
And 3-- so 3.182 is our t
value and then times 0.017.
And what you get, if
you do that out, is--
so when you're going to report
your 95% confidence interval,
you would add this number
and subtract this number
from your mean
and then report it
as a range in parentheses,
so 0.593,0.647.
And so that's your 95%
confidence interval.
And so what that's saying is
that there is a 95% chance
that the actual population mean
lies between these two numbers.
You are 95% sure that the
actual mean is in there.
So in your lab
reports, when it says
to calculate a 95%
confidence interval,
that is what we are looking for.
Other issues you may
run across in your data
is if you take
repeated measurements
of the same quantity.
You may have outliers.
And sometimes you
can look at your data
and say, wow, there's
definitely an outlier
here and other times--
but even if you
can do that, it's
nice to be able to
mathematically demonstrate
that it is, in fact, an outlier.
And so to avoid subjectivity
in whether you're tossing out
data points left or right, just
to make yourself look better,
you can use the
Q-test to help decide
whether a value can
be kept in a data set
or should be rejected
as an outlier.
And the way that the
Q-test works is you
take the absolute
value of the result
that you're worried about,
the questionable value.
Subtract it from its
nearest neighbor,
so whatever the next closest
value that you measured was.
And then divide it by the spread
of the data, which is just
your highest value
that you measured,
minus your lowest value
that you measured.
And then you have to look at
another table of standardized Q
values.
And if the Q that
you calculate is
greater than the Q in the
table for the number of data
points in the confidence
level that you want,
then you can reject
that point as an outlier
at that confidence level.
So the last question
on here is not
really related to the first
whole set of problems.
But if you took the
following measurements
for a concentration
of an NaOH solution,
are there any outliers
in that data set?
So what's our Q calculation
for this data set?
Which result might
be questionable?
2.86.
Yeah, that seems to be a little
bit higher than everybody else.
So our questionable
result is 2.86 minus--
AUDIENCE: 2.52.
SARAH HEWETT: 2.52 is its next
closest neighbor divided by--
how do we calculate
the spread of our data?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SARAH HEWETT: So 2.86,
which is our max.
And our minimum is 2.38.
So if you do that out, you
get 0.34 divided by 0.48.
So our Q value is 0.708.
Now, if we look at a table
of values for our Q-test--
so we can either calculate
it at 90% confident
that it's an outlier, 95%
confident that it's an outlier,
and all the way down.
So if we wanted to calculate
at 95% confidence level
that this point is
an outlier, then we
had how many data
points in this data set?
6.
So we'd look at 6.
95%.
Our Q value is 0.625.
So 0.708 is greater than 0.625.
So is it an outlier or not?
The Q that you calculate is
bigger than the Q in the table.
Then it is, indeed, an outlier.
And we can confidently
say that that does not
belong in our data set.
Ooh, we're working on it.
Come on.
So you can see that if
anything had changed,
like if we had had
fewer data points,
then it would not be an outlier.
Or if you wanted a
higher confidence level,
then it also would not
have been an outlier.
So it's a little more
strict, how far away
from the rest of
the points it has
to be before you can
call it an outlier.
Last thing we're
going to talk about
is doing the least
squares regression.
You'll make a bunch
of calibration curves
when you are doing different
measurements with UV-Vis
spectroscopy.
So in UV-Vis, which you'll
talk about in the next couple
of labs, the
absorbance of a sample
at a certain wavelength,
how much light it absorbs
is related to its concentration.
And this is a calibration
curve with the concentration
of bovine serum albumin protein
versus absorbance, which
you guys will be
making a similar one
in the catalase lab coming up.
So it assumes that
one variable is known.
So that's our
concentration, that we
have known concentrations,
and that all
of the variation in the
y-axis is linearly related
to our x values.
So that's one
assumption that you
have to have before you
are going to make a least
squares linear regression.
The way that you can
calculate all of the values
in a least squares regression--
which the whole idea of is
to get an equation for a line in
the form of y equals mx plus b.
So that's the point of all this.
And you'll have
different points.
And you want to
calculate a straight line
through all of your points.
So some of the terminology
that is associated with this
is the residual value.
And so that's your vertical
distance between a point
and the line of best fit.
So this is your residual value.
Each point has a residual value.
And the way that
the line of best fit
is generated in the
"least squares method"
is they take the square of
all of these residual values
and try to minimize it.
And so you can calculate
various quantities
if you take all of the
x values, subtract them
from the average
x and square them.
Then you'll get the Sxx.
You could do the same
thing with the y values
and then the x and the y values.
The slope of the line is
this value over this one.
To get the y-intercept,
you take the average y,
subtract it from the
slope and the average x.
And then the r squared.
This was a misprint in
your slide hand-outs.
It should be 1 minus this
quantity in the hand-outs.
The 1 is not on there.
And so the R
squared value, which
you've probably seen
before, is the coefficient
of determination.
And that is a measure of
how well this best fit
line can explain the variation
in y in a linear fashion.
So essentially, how
well do your points
fit a linear relationship?
Is that a good way
to explain your data?
So the best way to
generate this is in Excel.
You could calculate all
those quantities by hand
if you want to.
But Excel will do it for
you or your other favorite
mathematical software program.
You graph your points
as an x-y scatterplot.
Then you can right
click the data points.
And it'll say add trend line.
And then you can have options
to display the equation
and the R squared on the graph.
So you'll get your y equals
mx plus b equation there
and your R squared value there.
So you can see that this
line is-- this is not
a very linear set of data.
So your R squared,
ideally, is close to 1.
And this is close-ish to
1, but that is definitely
not a linear relationship.
You can get it higher than that.
And we'll talk
about that more when
you guys make your calibration
curves for the bovine serum
albumin.
The Coomassie blue
dye is only linear
in certain regions of
the calibration curve.
So you'll have to
calculate different lines
for different
pieces of the curve,
depending on what
your concentration is.
The last thing that we can do
to get more information out
of a set of linear data is
to use the LINEST program
in Excel.
And if you've never done this
before, you type in your data
as a series of x and y points.
And then instead
of graphing it--
well, you can graph it, too.
But in addition to graphing
it, you highlight a 2
by 5 area of empty cells.
And while that's highlighted
in the first cell,
you type in equals LINEST.
And then it'll prompt you
to highlight your y values,
then highlight your x values.
And then you can
type true and true.
And what that'll do
is if you type false,
it'll set the
y-intercept to zero.
And we don't want to force
our lines through zero.
So you will have your slope.
And then if you press
Control-Shift-Enter,
even on a Mac-- so on a Mac,
press Control, not Command.
Press Control-Shift-Enter.
And it'll give you
this array of data.
Once you get this
array of data, don't
try to change any
of these values
or Excel will get mad at
you, so just leave it.
And this is the key to what each
of the cells is telling you,
because it won't give
you this information.
You can look it up online,
or it'll be on these slides.
So your first thing--
it'll just give you
your slope and your intercept.
And then it'll give
you-- these are
the two that we
care about the most,
are the standard
deviation of the slope
and the standard deviation
of the y-intercept.
So sometimes in
this course, you'll
make graphs where the
slope is representative
of a certain quantity.
Or the y-intercept
is representative
of a certain quantity
if you're graphing
any equation in linear form.
So then you'll have
the standard deviations
of each of those measurements.
Then it'll also give
you your R squared
and a bunch of other information
that you want if you're doing
different statistical tests.